yeah I'm saying I'm going everything's
good Tyler Cameron has a mad love for
Jennifer Garner yeah you heard that
right
Tyler Cameron from Hannah Brown season
of The Bachelorette oh it's crazy let's
rewind on Wednesday Jennifer took to
Instagram to share her spin on this meme
a grid of four pics that assigns a
different photo and a different vibe for
a few social media networks LinkedIn
Facebook Instagram and tinder it was
really fun I loved that the forty seven
year-olds LinkedIn pic is super
professional a wholesome she's all
glammed out for insta and naturally
she's in a swimsuit for her faux tender
shot anyway when one fan commented on
the post writing he would have switched
the Instagram and tinder pics Jen
responded shoot is that why no one
swipes enter Tyler who swooped in like
the prince charming he is putting her
mind at ease writing I'm still swiping
right and I'm dying
wouldn't they be a match made in dating
app heaven of course the tinder joke was
all in jest Jennifer is currently seeing
41 year-old businessman John Miller and
in June a source told et that the couple
isn't very much dating and are together
more and more Lala as for Tyler he spent
some time with Gigi Hadid last year we
saw some very public photos of you and
Gigi Hadid yeah so where you guys at
right now
just friends yeah where we're at our
relationship is need to be public it's
she's good she's good people she's an
amazing person and we're just keeping it
keeping it friendly she's an amazing
person we've had great time ago but most
recently he's been linked to Kylie
Jenner's bestie Stassi the two spent New
Year's Eve together in Miami after they
were seen getting cozy in November and
when et caught up with Tyler in October
he didn't exactly shoot down the idea of
returning to reality TV as the bachelor
maybe down the road but right now my
heart really wasn't at a loss of what
so I wasn't where I needed to be right
now but down the road who knows if I
were going to make the social media grid
for Tyler it would look something like
this
LinkedIn Facebook Instagram tinder of
course Jen isn't the only celeb to get
in on the trend
Dolly Parton posted this collage with
the caption get you a woman who can do
it all well I'm excited about it Ellen
shared her version writing when my agent
asks if I can play different roles Kerry
Washington
straight-up posted a lingerie pick for
her tinder shot pretty awesome then
there was Andy Cohen who nailed it it's
perfect
gotta love a viral insta meme I mean
what a time to be alive of course you
can count on et to bring you all the
latest on Jennifer Garner and Tyler
Cameron so make sure to keep it locked
right here until next time I'm Hallie
Stephens bye for now
[Music]